i often find myself surprised when i'm
on set and
it's time to do a scene and this
person's been around and then all of a
sudden
the camera's rolling and this like they
morph into something else
how do you know an actor is the real
deal i suppose
like anything
uh there are many different ways
for actors to be you know quote unquote
good or bad
and you know i think you can
i've started to think about them a
little bit like athletes
and
you know some work harder than others
some have some natural talent um
but there are also
specialty
kind of approaches like
uh
let's say like a
a quirky actor you know like a specialty
three-point shooter it doesn't mean that
this person is good at all the things
but cast correctly casting i guess is
really part of it
if they're in the right spot you put
them in a position to succeed so one
person can really shine
if they're in the right role and it's a
well-written role of course
whereas that same person you could see
on a different set on a different day in
a different role and you're like
i don't know about that like it's so
there are a number of factors that said
every once in a while and i would not
know how to to quantify it but every
once in a while i find myself
behind the camera and i'm watching
something i'm like oh this person's
going to be around forever like you
there's just something
um you know i mean i guess back in the
day you would think of that like oh
they've got it
you know i
i hesitate to put it that way but that
said i have seen that i've seen actors
were like oh like that's me i had i had
the good fortune of working with um
matt damon on on a tiny little like a
youtube thing
i watched george clooney work
and
they are so prepared
and so comfortable there's like a
confidence that they carry with them
they treated everybody around them uh
phenomenally well they were very loose
but then when it came to time to work
they could snap right in you could tell
they had done the work
so all
all of this stuff whereas other actors
come they don't know their lines and so
i think part of it is just preparation
truly
and
on set that comes across as like wow
they're really talented but really it's
just that they put in the work
so i think that's part of it but
you know i i
i often find myself surprised when i'm
on set and
it's time to do a scene and this
person's been around and then all of a
sudden
the camera's rolling and this like they
morph into something else so
i don't know where some of these things
come from uh i know some of it is work
it's prep
but some of it that maybe there is just
a natural thing i don't know i don't
know it's a little bit of magic i think
i don't know
i i continue to wonder the same thing
yeah
what other qualities are you looking for
in an actor you know
it's interesting so for me because i
have no power over choosing an actor
in my position as a cinematographer the
actors are
chosen so
whoever's there
like i'm gonna do
whatever i can do with them
there are little treats that some actors
bring um
there are some actors who
just physically their eyes will catch a
light really well they have like big or
big brown eyes let's say and they just
almost no matter where they are
they'll always catch a little bit of
light and then some actors their eyes
are a little like deeper i think i have
kind of smallish eyes and it can get
tricky because like an eye light can go
a long way
when you're lighting somebody in terms
of creating an empathy there's something
really magical about an highlight and
some actors it's hard to get the eye
light you're like trying to find the
spot and some of them won't take it so i
mean that's a
that's a purely physical thing that they
have no control over so there are like
treats like that sometimes i'm like all
this and you know skin tones different
actors they have you're just like oh
this like takes the
the warmth really well so there are
little things like that
but a um
i mean i guess as with most people on a
set there really is
to somebody being
um
kind and professional being prepared
that's a actually
preparation is maybe one of the biggest
things because
we i've a number of times in my life we
i have with the director we plan this
shot where oh they're going to take them
out the door we're going to dolly all
the way down and then they sit here and
then they're going to interact with this
person and get in their car and go
and then the actor can't get through
their lines and you have to
reapproach the entire scene and do it
because somebody doesn't know their
lines
and sometimes that's hard because they
have a ton of lines and that's brutal i
wouldn't be able to do that but
sometimes it's a lack of preparation so
i guess
yeah i suppose for all the all the
random things i just named
i want a prepared actor somebody is
taking it seriously because like
it it affects
my ability to do a good job if somebody
comes in unprepared
so i think something as basic as that is
about all you can ask from somebody is
don't be a dick and be prepared
that's that goes a long way
so if someone is not prepared then
you're doing numerous retakes people are
reading them their lines
it's constant yeah there's there's
constant like you have to reset you have
to take it all in pieces and if they can
only get a few lines at a time it means
you have to cut to something else
because in the edit you need when
they're when they're resetting
you have to cut so it's forcing your
hand
in an edit and you have to rethink the
way you're building a scene which can
mean this is not the way we intended or
this isn't this isn't going to feel the
way we want this to feel
uh but you have to you know because and
and look
i say that as though it's really easy
that you know you're doing a shoot
especially
if there's you know one or two lead
characters
and they have to memorize lines for 15
weeks
every day and scripts are being
rewritten
it is a big ask that is a big load that
these actors are carrying like i really
i empathize with them it's really hard
acting is i know we all tend to think of
it as like oh celebrity and you're
famous and
it is brutal it is hard work especially
if you're on a tv show scripts are
changing you have
tons of dialogue and then on top of that
you have all these people whispering in
your ear i have to gauge
when
we do it let's say we're shooting a
scene and an actor you know on top of
all their lines maybe a director gives
them direct oh no this part don't forget
you need to be sad in this little thing
but then come back up but then for me
i maybe need an actor to land in a
certain spot and maybe they haven't and
i will have to gauge going back to
reading the room
if they seem overwhelmed
i won't give them that note on the first
take i will like let them get a little
more comfortable and then if i can do
anything on my side to adjust maybe we
tweak a light maybe i move my camera
then i'll do that otherwise i'm waiting
until they're comfortable and then as
gently as i can just like hey don't
forget like after you get up from the
dinner table i need you to land in this
area and i have to be very careful
because
i am
lower priority you want the performance
to to work if the performance doesn't
work it doesn't matter how pretty my
light is
you want the performance to lead so for
me
i have to make sure an actor is
comfortable and that they feel
comfortable with me and then gauging
when they're too overwhelmed or it's
okay now to give them a no or sometimes
you know some directors
prefer me to give notes sometimes i go
to the director and i say hey you need
to remind them that they have to get to
this area and things like that so there
are lots of little things that actors
are constantly being bombarded with it's
it's
so i think for for a cinematographer
or a camera operator uh it's really
important to have empathy and realize
that these actors even if you don't like
them
they are carrying a lot and you need to
protect them and their space their head
space and the physical space that you're
working in
yeah that's why i always and i've i've
said this numerous times when people say
oh well so-and-so doesn't want to hang
out in between takes and they just go
back into their dressing room i think
that they would need that time oh man i
would not i would definitely not hang
out in between takes like there's no way
there's just so much and people you know
especially if um an actor has any kind
of celebrity people get a little you
know googly eyed and a little and they
want to interact they want to be able to
go home to their spouse and just be like
you know i was talking with george
clooney about chicken today
but
they are there's so much going on for
them so i do my best to like just stay
out of their way
because there's there's really a lot of
people are really pulling at actors
attentions same with directors too but
it does they don't have usually that
celebrity attached and people get
you know people get weird around
celebrity unfortunately
you